remote work has made people lazy the
average hours worked per day has dropped
from 8.2 hours per day in 2019 to just
5.7 hours per day in 2023 in other words
remote hybrid workers which now
encompasses a third of all Americans
work less than 30 hours per week on
average and it's no wonder why some
companies like Tesla and apple are
adamant that people return to the office
but most companies and even the
government are just rolling with it take
Google for example back in 2021 they had
all this press about returning to the
office but just last month they
basically officially gave up on this
effort by putting 1.4 million square
feet worth of office space up for a
sublease but why are companies putting
up with this clearly people tend to work
less from home well though people do
tend to work less total hours they
actually tend to be more productive they
don't have to worry about spending an
hour on commuting each way or packing
lunch or buying lunch or waking up super
early or any of the other cons that come
with in-person work they're able to
focus on just work itself making them
more efficient and productive for the
hours that they do work in fact it's
estimated that the modern hybrid economy
is five percent more productive than the
traditional in-person economy as such
some companies are even taking this to
the next level by experimenting with
four day work weeks and even 20 hour
work weeks the idea is that while people
work substantially as ours overall
productivity shouldn't change all that
much this brings up the question are 30
hour and 20 hour work weeks the future
of office jobs well I believe the answer
is absolutely in fact I think it's just
a matter of time until a big tech
company experiments with such a schedule
officially you see smaller work weeks
don't just work from a logical
perspective but from a cynical
perspective as well so join me as we
take a look at how smaller work weeks
will not only make tech companies more
productive but infinitely more
profitable
foreign
for starters working 8 hours a day is
complete BS for most office workers most
of the time they're just waiting on
someone else sitting in useless meetings
or just working slowly in fact during an
eight hour work day the average worker
only spends 4 hours and 12 minutes
actually doing work the rest of the day
is spent on surfing the internet social
media texting bathroom breaks and
socializing with co-workers now of
course before you get mad in the
comments let me acknowledge that this
isn't true for all jobs especially those
that require manual labor if you're a
mechanic or a truck driver or a plumber
this is obviously not the case not only
can these people work a full eight hours
a day but they can actually be more or
less productive the entire time the Sim
however cannot be said about office
workers in fact Studies have found that
even the most productive office workers
are only able to be productive for six
hours per day in other words even the
most productive office workers waste two
hours every single day so really there's
no reason for work weeks to be longer
than 30 hours per week and remote work
is proving exactly this when people work
from home they definitely have more
distractions they might be taking care
of their children or working on a house
project or cooking or whatever else but
despite this remote workers are far more
productive because they tend to approach
work in a completely different light
when you're forced to be at work for
eight hours you can actually tend to
work slower because there's no benefit
to working faster you have to be there
for all eight hours even if you finish
within four or five hours so people tend
to stretch out the work throughout the
entire day also when people are in
person they feel less of a need to prove
themselves to their managers and bosses
their presence itself goes a long way in
showing that they're committed and
working hard when they're working from
home however it's a whole other ball
game suddenly employees are judged
solely on their output as opposed to
their presence I mean let's be honest
everyone knows that you can just have
teams open and move them hours every 10
minutes so no manager really takes
online hours all that seriously it's all
about progress and work output as such
employees also tend to focus on hitting
a certain Milestone or getting something
done within a workday as opposed to
working an arbitrary number of hours
it's actually kind of a motivating
factor if they can just focus on getting
X item done they can just be done for
the entire day so they're incentivized
to work harder and more efficiently
during the hours that they do work also
given that they now have more downtime
employees are in a much better state of
mind they're more relaxed less stressed
and just happier in general in fact one
study found that remote work increases
employee Happiness by 20 which of course
leads to more productivity not to
mention it with remote and hybrid work
companies are able to get away with less
office space less corporate food less
electricity less internet basically less
of everything so it's really a win-win
scenario for companies happier employees
less costs and more productivity and if
you don't believe me just take it from
history
foreign
work weeks themselves are actually a
super new invention in fact they haven't
even been around for a hundred years yet
40 hour work weeks didn't even become a
lot till 1940 when the fair labor
standards Act was amended before this
Factory workers would generally work 12
to 16 hours a day for six days a week
their only off day was Sunday so that
they could go to church this meant that
the average employee was generally
working about a hundred hours every
single week of course there were
activists in the labor unions who were
trying to bring this down for decades
but nothing really changed until Henry
Ford stepped in in 1926 Ford would
become the first major company to
implement a 40-hour work week they were
essentially cutting down working hours
by over half but they kept the pay the
same this was an insane development Ford
was already a top paying company similar
to Tech companies today in fact Ford was
already paying nearly two times the
average Factory salary for both men and
women and now they were gonna cut down
working hours by 60 I mean this was
ludicrous surely their productivity
would plummet given how labor-intensive
building cars is but this didn't happen
in fact the exact opposite happened Ford
was already a desirable place to work
but this made Ford the place to be for
the working class the amount of pride
and loyalty that Ford saw from their
Factory workers was unprecedented and
though they were only working eight
hours a day for its productivity per
hour was higher than ever but despite
this massive success other companies
were obviously hesitant in implementing
a similar work schedule the argument was
oh it may work for Ford but it wouldn't
work for us but over time They too had
to make it work not because of laws or
strikes or protests or any of that but
simply because of supply and demand for
obvious reasons all of the best welders
and Painters and designers and
inspectors walked over to Ford and the
other companies that were offering such
perks the only people left at companies
like GM who were on blank reduced hours
were people who literally had no other
choice this meant that employee morale
and thus productivity fell lava Cliff at
these companies so they really had no
choice but to follow suit now nearly a
hundred years later were met with a
similar set of Crossroads remote work
has made it clear that 40 hour work
weeks are very much outdated and this is
really not surprising thanks to
automation Tech and now ai much of the
things that humans work on aren't
exactly effort dependent rather they're
creativity dependent which is a limited
resource just because a ux engineer at
Google works longer doesn't mean that
the UI will actually turn out to be more
visually pleasing or intuitive of course
this logic is most applicable for tech
companies and that's why they'd be the
ones leading the way similar to Ford so
while a reduction from 40 hours down to
30 hours or even 20 hours may seem crazy
at first glance it's really not we saw a
much greater decrease just a hundred
years ago and that was definitely for
the better moreover there is a much more
cynical reason for reducing working
hours anyway
foreign
even on the surface there's obviously a
lot of cynical benefits to reducing
working hours companies like Google and
Facebook can easily improve their brand
image without sacrificing on
productivity or progress similarly they
can reduce operating expenses by
spending Less on Office Buildings but
all of that is just a bonus there is a
much darker reason to produce working
hours that Henry Ford was well aware of
by substantially increasing wages and
decreasing working hours Ford ensured
that his employees not only had time to
enjoy the benefits of a car but also the
money to afford a car before this only
the royalty could afford cars with
substantially limited Ford's reach but
by making this pivot Ford was not only
able to make cars affordable for his own
employees but the entirety of the
working class across America
fun fact cars were more affordable for
low-level Factory workers at Ford 100
years ago than they are for the average
American today Ford was paying a minimum
wage of five dollars per day which meant
that it would take a Ford employee at
most 11 weeks to afford a 260 Model T
today the median income in the US is
forty four thousand dollars but to even
a four day base level Toyota Corolla it
would take 26 weeks of income no wonder
cars became so popular but anyway tech
companies today are in the perfect
position to do the exact same thing but
with tech these companies are very much
the Ford of the 21st century they have
the most power control and influence so
you can bet that if they reduce working
hours other companies will be forced to
follow along not just within the us but
internationally sure work hours May not
drop all the way to 20 hours across the
world for countries that tend to work
more hours may drop from 100 to 80 or 80
to 70. given that most tech companies
operate off of free product they don't
even need people to have more money they
just need people to have more time in an
Ideal World a 20-hour work week would
mean that people spend more time with
family and friends and on trips and
relaxation and all of that but you can
bet that if a 20-hour work week were to
actually be implemented most people
would just spend more time on their
phones than social media and guess who
owns these platforms it's of course the
tech companies right now the average
person only spends 2 hours and 31
minutes per day on social media but with
the 20-hour work weeks this could easily
go up to four or five hours per day
which would essentially double the
income of these platforms so it really
doesn't even matter if shorter work
weeks marginally affect the productivity
of these companies they'd essentially be
trading 10 or 20 less productivity from
their 100 or 200 000 employees in return
for hours of time from billions of
people and the best part is that they'll
look like they're good guys who are on
the employee side and it's really a 200
IQ move as Henry Ford declared every man
needs more than one day a week for rest
and Recreation I mean to buy Model T
cars similarly tech companies can
declare every person needs more than 16
hours a day for rest and record I mean
to use our platforms as much as possible
as this is the real reason that
companies will push for shorter and
shorter work weeks and embrace remote
work simply it makes more business sense
something else that's
counter-intuitively more profitable is
giving up profitability check out this
video to learn more but until then I'm
Hari I'll see you guys on the next one